hi we're the try guys I'm teeth I'm hot
I want to be my new catchphrase
imitations this is my dad he's here
we're gonna imitate each other we're
gonna imitate each other dad are you
good at imitations oh great
ring ring ring hey Zack how are you no
hey no you're Zack hey Dad
how's it going hey how's it going hi dad
hi Eugene how are you I'm fine can I
call you back I'm really busy I'll call
you bet I I'm just I'm just so busy at
work there's so much going on I'm doing
five videos at once and I'm writing
something at a man editing three more I
was up all night last night we got this
new video idea we want to try oh we
think we want you to be in it Oh me ha
ha ha gosh I don't know are you exercise
how do you eat thank you I have to know
okay well I'm gonna give you back to mom
cool yeah
okay so goodbye I'll call you back okay
okay bye well that's sad when I hear
back back oh this is my dad whenever we
go anywhere in public
Brenda Brenda Eugene look at that tree
Wow nice tree when my dad meets my dog
beam his he gets a really high-pitched
voice hey he just kind of stands in from
the TV with his arms you know like this
we're just asking like do you want to
see he's like no no no I'm just I'm just
I'm just walking in and out oh oh look
at that rock you see that rock that is
true that is a nice rug
here's Ned would be Oh like I would
never do that I've seen the whole thing
I know the beginning I know I know the
beginning and he's the guy with the
thing it's great when he was a kid he
was really shy Oh God Yoo Jin Yoo Jin
I'll be there 10 minutes I want the
candy no knows that come on we have to
go I want the candy no I want the candy
Zac hey Dad
oh hey Keith let's play frisbee
you do they spit ten minutes
a little-bitty song Zach no Zach get up
dad
Zach dad stop it Zach I'm not that bad
happen to have any time when are we
gonna do not g string hair you still
doing it yeah you met I just need you to
listen I know I look now you know other
people your feelings yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah tires choose feelings make
them say things they don't mean feels
like he's like pika Chu I'm sure you get
that reference
yeah I'm not doing imitation I'm not do
it hey this is peace you're watching the
tree I gotta dance imitate their sons
and let me tell you I
it's so cute being a father it is
important to talk about my wife I cannot
do it we have to listen to me hey
there's no boy in the video though cha
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha cha shower
shower doors up wake up I'm still slim
just a moment
shower time shower times I was out
shower times our times our time tchau
tchau showers up they can
time to wake up and stuff you all day
go away get it straight it's our time to
our time shower shower shower time key
it's time to get up it's time to get in
the shower and clean up it's time to get
up
it's our time all right
I don't think we ever did you know we
haven't had that talk yet yeah I'm still
back is still young vision that if you
have a six you must be careful with
disease in the penis whatever you do
just make sure you use protection and if
you do anything with but know about anal
elasticity tell me I'm not lying that's
true right turn on snakes have you seen
me sad before
I don't know that I have
[Music]
actually the only time I've seen my dad
cry is he loves the musical rent and I
do trust me I agree and seriously you
don't like red wheat welded I mean the
only time I remember Ned crying really
is one at my grandfather's funeral yeah
he was really broken up yeah I mean do
you have any impressions of your dad you
know I always he was stoic you know to
me is the greatest guy in the world
greatest man in the world so I never met
your dad well that that's another thing
I grew up with our Father yeah I don't
remember his face I only picked I have a
very old a yellow peach I can see it so
for me you know father figures very
different I are hopeless we get over
that constantly on getting over sadness
rather than dwelling on it so that's why
I'm hard to figure you know how to
imitate each other on that we don't say
I love you very much
rediff you got a family never says it
like on the phone like everyone else I
feel like lots of families always see
that we're just like that we just kind
of are aware of that what we say it a
lot you have two versions to see they're
like the G quick like all right love you
are like I love you you spend more time
analyzing me than I the funniest thing
about you dad the way you hug people is
like the most delightfully nervous okay
anyone do it is like this I love you Ned
love you dad well we know we're lovers
yeah that's true we know it so we don't
have to say I love you I'm not you
do you want to keep shooting this video
no okay you were to stop right okay
I know anything no come on can you try
it oh I am your daddy listen to me well
that's bad that was you know it's okay
yeah it's okay you're not you're not you
need that you're not an actor
thank you